this morning on the dish
a passion for pasta and all the food of
his native italy
frank di pasquale is one of the most
successful tours in boston's
north end the city's little italy along
with seven dining venues he has dozens
of other ventures
including a pasta shop a bakery even a
hotel
and a magazine he didn't start out in
the field but
soon found food was his first love and
it all began
with a simple sandwich this is our love
this is our passion
this is what we live for it's just the
love of what we do
with a veritable feast before him boston
restaurateur frank di pasquale
speaks from the heart i wake up i can't
wait
to see a new dish that the chef is
making i can't wait to see the smile on
the customer's face as they're sipping
their wine or eating the food or
saying something nice on the way out
this array of
favorite deposqually ventures dishes
includes zucchini pasta with pravolla
parmigiano and reggiano
margarita pizza with hand crushed
tomatoes gnocchiala sorrentina
even a signature espresso martini but
dipasquale
sets his sights on the simple sandwich
he says started it all
homemade prosciutto de palma buffalo
mozzarella
tomatoes mine ripe tomatoes extra virgin
olive oil
a little bit of basil my first
restaurant is named under that
particular sandwich and we started it as
a panino and we turned it into a
trattoria
which happened in 1987 which is i think
about 34 years ago longer than we wanted
and here we are today with seven
different restaurants
dipasquale's father was the first to
dream of building a food business here
in the united states
bringing his family to boston from san
giuseppe italy
the city's north end quickly became home
this is honestly the greatest
neighborhood probably in the country
it's because people make places places
don't make people
all right guys and outside of every door
you will see
either an owner or a manager greeting
you loving you
hugging you my father was here all the
time making sure that naples won the
soccer match of the week
and we had espressos here and he would
buy me a little taroni
and or confetti and i was always by his
side
from when i was four years old till the
the day he passed away
just 15 at the time of his father's
death depasquale says
that's when he became the man of the
family after college he launched his
first business
a shoe store i didn't like the fact that
i had to sit there all day long and
and size people's feet and so so i said
you know something my
my real passion is food so let me get
started with food that's when that first
north end restaurant il penino came to
be this
started off as a simple sandwich shop
deep esquali traces his culinary
yearnings
to his trips back to italy most of my
friends they'd be looking at the
beautiful girls at the beach
but i spent most of my time in kitchens
in restaurants because
that was my passion to watch the pizza
man the way he slapped the pizza how he
turned it in the pizza oven
how he crushed the tomatoes by hand i
watched the people make the zucchini
pasta the mothers
make the gnocchi it was a passion it was
lovely everything that i always wanted
to be
it's those italian traditions that de
pisquale has brought to each of his
restaurant ventures
like homemade buffalo mozzarella
and fresh baked bread but it's more than
just the food
i always wanted to be the best and i
always say it in all my meetings
people don't remember who comes in
second so my
stride was to be the very best
restaurant that i could be and i hired
the right people to do the right job
you brought chefs over from italy i
brought chefs over from italy and a lot
of them
ended up staying here a lot of them
ended up marrying here and a lot of them
ended up never leaving again and they're
still a part of my team
a team that has a huge footprint in that
same north end dipasquale first
wandered in as a child and in some ways
not much has changed we start every
morning at my coffee shop we have our
espresso
cappuccino and we talk about last night
we talk about our food
like i said before this is the greatest
community in the country we help each
other with menus we help each other
with buying we if someone runs out of a
certain product they could definitely
come to my restaurant
or i could go to their restaurant frank
that seems so
rare to me because you are competitors
and you're right next door that you
would help each other
in that way but competitors
bring up our game so so we all become a
little bit better
that community bond never more important
than during the pandemic
with the restaurant industry one of the
hardest hit
well it's a different world and we're
adjusting to it we're buying
umbrellas together we're buying outdoor
furniture together to save a few dollars
we're buying barriers we're teaching
each other the distancing
and it's been a tough time but honestly
we begged
to have outside seating for as long as
i've been here and that's
at least 34 years and it took a pandemic
to get us here
but you have it now the unofficial mayor
of the north end
deposquali would be the one to find the
positive spin
he's also the one that even in tough
times is trying to look ahead
his next project a joint venture in
boston's new encore casino hotel
we're going to have a pizzeria very
similar to the one that i have at
quattro
how old are you oh do i have to say you
don't if you if you don't want to
68. do you ever going on 55.
i was going to say do you ever see not
working at this pace
i think i i i think with the espresso
martinis and
and um and the espressos that i have
every single day which is usually about
five or six of them
um it keeps me going and i i think i'm
gonna hit
uh i'm gonna try to hit that hundred
someday also can i say cheers to that
cheers to that and as we toast that
future
dipasquale can't help but turn to the
past in reflecting upon
all of his success if you could have
this meal
with anyone past or present who would it
be oh wow
wow i think i think it would be with my
father
i think my father joseph i mean he had
the vision to come to america and give
us this opportunity
and i'm not going to waste it he hasn't
you taste that food there's love in that
food i blew it
i was reminded by brian applegate our
executive producer
espresso martinis it would have been so
easy to bring to you so
espresso martinis i thought you were
already bringing them
you were fair yeah i did i did yeah
post show and some buffalo mozzarella
too buffalo
good it's all good